الجيش الاوكراني قال ان روسيا تخطط لهجوم
واسع في زابولوجيا بحلول الذكرى السنويه
الاولى للحرب خلال الشهر الجاري ياتي ذلك
بعد اعلان وزاره الدفاع الروسيه استهدافه
منشات عسكريه اوكرانيه في المنطقه الغربيه
بصواريخ تورنادو اس مؤكده دقتها في اصابه
الهدف
جديد الوضع الميداني انما في الجنوب
نتابعها من خرسون مع مراسل الجزيره تامر
الصمادي ومن دنيتك نتابع ايضا مراسله
الجزيره رانيا الدريدي في الموقف الروسي
وما تورده القوات
الاوكرانيه المواليه
لروسيا في دنيا لنبدا معك رانيا باخر
التطورات انطلاقا مما ذكرته وزاره الدفاع
والقوات المواليه لروسيا
يعني لو بدانا بالحديث عن خسائر القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
اشارت الى ان الجانب الاوكراني تكبر خسائر
فادحه الحديث يدور عن القضاء خلال اليوم
الماضي على اكثر من 220 عسكريا اوكرانيا
في مختلف الجبهات ولكن هنا لابد من
الاشاره الى ان الخسائر الاكبر للقوات
الاوكرانيه يعني تاتي من نصيب منطقه
محور الجنوبي بالاضافه الى محور كراسي
لماما لوحده خلال الساعات الاربعه
والعشرين الماضيه تم القضاء على اكثر من
100 عسكري اوكراني فضلا عن ذلك تستمر
القوات المسلحه الروسيه برصد وضرب الاهداف
العسكريه لا سيما مستودعات الاسلحه
والذخائر وفي هذا الاطار تم تدمير
مستودعين للاسلحه والذخائر التابعه للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه في منطقتي كرسون وايضا
في مدينه اوغلي الواقعه في مقاطعه
على الصعيد الانساني والميداني في ان واحد
حسن اليوم مدينه دانيت شهدت قصفا اوكرانيا
شهد حي اكيد قصفا طال احد المباني السكنيه
التي يعني دمر جزء منها وحاليا لا يزال
عدد من الاشخاص يتواجدون تحت الانقاض فضلا
عن ذلك تم استهداف ايضا احياء سكنيه في
مدينه جولفكا خلال هذا القصف لقي شخص حتى
هو اصيب مدنيان بجروحنا هيك عن ان يعني
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه بحسب معطيات
سلطات دانياسك يعني قصفت خلال اليوم
الماضي هذه المنطقه باكثر من 150 قضيه
طالت سبعه احياء سكنيه على الصعيد
الميداني المعارك الاكثر احتداما تاتي من
نصيب منطقتي ومدينتي
قوات باجنر وفقا للمعطيات الصادره عن هذه
الشركه العسكريه الخاصه تتقدم نحو الشمال
وايضا نحو الجنوب فضلا عن ذلك تتحدث عن
توسيع رقعه العمليات العسكريه وروحات
المناطق التي تمت السيطره عليها في داخل
المدينه تلك يعني المناطق يعني تعود الى
المناطق الجنوبيه وفي دار حتى هذه اللحظه
حسن المعارك لا تزال تروح مكانها هناك
حصار على شبه هلال للمناطق الشرقيه
والجنوبيه الشرقيه في منطقه اوغليدار وقطع
لكل الطرق التي تحصل القوات الاوكرانيه
للامدادات العسكريه والقوى البشريه لدعمها
في داخل المدينه والمعارك دائره في قلبها
هناك تبادل للقصف المدفعي بين الجانبين
نتحول الى الجنوب مع تامر الصمادي ان كانت
هناك اي
تعليقات
اوكرانيه لما تريده وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
خصوصا وان اوكرانيا تتخوف من هجوم واسع في
الذكرى الاولى للحرب طبعا اضافه الى ما
يحصل حاليا في خرسون وزابولوجيا تامر
فعل حسن الموقع الاوكراني الروايه
الاوكرانيه لا تتغير تقول بان الوضع في
الشرق الاوكراني صعب وصعب جدا لكنها تقول
بان القوات الخاصه بها تواصل صد الهجمات
المتواصله على كامل المحاور في دنيتسكو
لكن اسمح لي ان ابدا من هنا ايضا
واتوسع هنا في خيرسون في الجنوب حيث شهدنا
ونشهد منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى وحتى هذه
اللحظه تكثيفا من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه
لاستخدام
المدفعيه باتجاه مواقع سيطره القوات
الروسيه هنا في خرسون على الضفه الشرقيه
تحديدا ونحن ننتظر هذا الهواء القصف
المدفعي الاوكراني في المحيط الذي نقف فيه
كان متواصلا ومكثفا وعنيفا للغايه باتجاه
تلك المواقع قياده عمليات الجنوب
الاوكرانيه تحدثت طيله هذا اليوم عن قصف
خطوط الامداد من شبه جزيره باتجاه المواقع
التي تتواجد فيها القوات الروسيه في
خيرسون وهي تتواجد بالتاكيد عند الضفه
الشرقيه من نهر دنيبر تتحدث قياده عمليات
الجنوب الاوكرانيه عن خسائر فادحه في
العتاد والارواح بالنسبه للقوات الروسيه
وتقول بانها تعمل كل ما بوسعها من اجل
اخراج القوات الروسيه وابعادها الى الخطوط
الخلفيه تقول بان هنالك انسحابات متكرره
شهدتها خلال الايام الماضيه واليومين
الماضيين تحديدا لبعض القوات الروسيه من
الخطوط المتقدمه باتجاه خطوط خلفيه لكن في
الحقيقه الوضع الانساني حسن صعب للغايه
هنا في خيرسون لا سيما ان القصف الروسي
تواصل منذ الليله الماضيه وصباح هذا اليوم
على البنيه التحتيه المدنيه وفقا للسلطات
المحليه الاوكرانيه هنا في المدينه هذا
القصف وفقا للروايه الاوكرانيه ادى الى
انقطاعات واسعه وكبيره وهائله تيار
الكهربائي عن عموم مقاطعه خيرسون بالاضافه
الى انقطاع المياه انقطاع المياه هذا
تواصل ايضا في مقاطعه ميكولايب منذ يوم
امس والمدينه من دون مياه وحتى في مقاطعه
اوديسا نتيجه للضربات الصاروخيه السابقه
للقوات الروسيه وفقا للاداره العسكريه
هناك فان كامل مقاطعه اوديسا الان باتت
بلا كهرباء وهو ما دفع الحكومه نهايه حسن
ما دفع الحكومه الاوكرانيه الى الاعاز او
رئيس الحكومه الاوكرانيه للاعاز لوزير
خارجيه بالتواصل مع تركيا من اجل ارسال
خلال الساعه الماضيه من اجل ارسال سفينه
تتواجد فيها محطه للطاقه من اجل تعويض
الاضرار في اوديسيا والحديث عن خسائر
كبيره فيما يتعلق بالطاقه في اوديسا وهو
ما ادى كما قلت الى انقطاع كامل التيار
الكهربائي نهايه في زبالوجيا هنالك تحذير
اوكراني من هجوم واسع على المقاطعه على
سيما في الذكرى السنويه الاولى الحرب
الروسيه والقوات الاوكرانيه تقول بانها
عززت من دفاعاتها من اجراءاتها للتعامل مع
اي تطور روسي هناك
شكرا جزيلا لك من خرسون وشكرا من دنيتك
لرانيا الدريدي